hospitalizations are also rising
with sustained growth over the past
month and once again
they will rise too but we should be
encouraged
that hospitalizations are far lower than
they were at the point during at this
point during the previous wave
just as we should be encouraged that
people over the age of 65
who are more likely to have had both
doses of the vaccines
they make up 31 percent of covered
admissions last week
compared to 61 in january
this is further evidence that our
vaccination program
is doing its job and protecting the nhs
and as more people get the job our
protective wall
is getting stronger still we will stay
vigilant
and keep a very close eye on the data as
well as the impact of long coving
where we're investing 50 million pounds
into new research
but on the basis of the evidence in
front of us
we do not believe that infection rates
will be unsustainable put unsustainable
pressure on the nhs
it's so important that everyone still
does their bit in helping the nhs to
stand strong
and the best thing that each and every
one of us can do if we haven't done
already
is get the jab and crucially get both
doses
you